so
i'm going to be talking about responsive
about typography techniques like snook
just said
and it's actually been a really fun day
so far i mean css conf has been pretty
cool for a first time around don't you
think
so to start off thanks so much for you
guys for having me it's been really
awesome and
like pretty like it's a big honor to be
at the first time of a conference that's
really really cool
i also appreciate all of you guys
letting me talk about typography
because i don't know if you noticed but
we've been talking about a lot of like
pretty crazy stuff
um pretty serious stuff and i'm like
let's talk about type yay
so yay at least one other person so a
couple things that i do
um i am the managing editor of
creative.js and basically we collect up
a bunch of cool
tutorials and articles and things about
fun stuff people are doing with
javascript
um we also teach some workshops i teach
one of those workshops
obviously the coolest of all the
workshops that's the creator.js for
designers um because designers are the
coolest obviously
i also run web design day which is a day
kind of like this except in pittsburgh
so we don't have any
ocean or sun so anyways um but we do
talk about web design and a lot
so i've been running that for a while um
also i think just like last week i
released or five simple steps released
um
my book the pocket guide to css
animations it has exactly nothing to do
with what i'm talking about today
like literally nothing at all there will
be no talk of animations but if you're
into those you might want to check it
out
so um yeah
i just realized one thing that is
missing
and i'm not sure if i can get it back
sorry
that's how you can tell i'm canadian i
just apologized for fixing my screen
oh you guys are gonna need there's gonna
be better jokes than that okay so
we've just been talking about things
like viewport sizes and checkboxes and
all this stuff and i figured that maybe
you know to get everyone thinking about
type and to get in like a typography
kind of move we could play a little game
maybe up for it okay good you guys are a
little bit alive so
um the game i want to play is called
font or
fish um basically oops well we already
got to the first question i put a name
up on the screen you tell me if you
think it's a font or a fish so this one
fish yay oh and don't you love these
like keynote transitions amazing
all right how about this one yes you
guys are a little too good i should have
made these harder
this one no it's a fish
yay i stumped you on one but this is fun
isn't it
um how about this one yes it's a fish
isn't he cute uh last one
yes awesome all right so everyone's
about set to start talking about
typography right yeah
oh i'm so glad you guys played my game
that's really cool um
all right so a couple things we have in
this talk well list of exactly four
actually we're gonna talk about or i'm
gonna show you some three approaches
for awesomely readable body text in
responsive design um
i'm gonna hopefully prove to you that
even just the smallest bit of attention
to your type
can give you huge awesome results for
your designs there's only one very sad
cat
i'm sorry and any number of terrible
jokes might be sorry about that too
but really the main thing is there's no
one way to do any of this stuff i'm
sharing what works for me and what seems
to work for some other people i hang out
with as well um but i find that
responsive design has really changed my
process a lot and it's very much
evolving
so this is the stuff i'm doing now maybe
i'll come up with a better idea tomorrow
maybe you guys will come up with a
better idea tomorrow
and that's kind of the fun part about
sharing so
oh well let's start with some science
bad typography probably never killed
anyone i put probably in just in case
there's any like lawyers or
fact-checking people in the world maybe
it has happened but chances are it
hasn't happened very often
um so
you know but there's also been the worst
thing that could probably happen with
bad typography is you can look a little
bad maybe you can look a little bit like
out of style a little bit
awkward a little bit ugly but it's not
really going to hurt anything
um you know worst thing you might look a
little below average but you're not
going to be like
painfully hurting anyone there's been
some scientific studies even
particularly this one the aesthetics of
reading it's very tiny on the screen but
whatever
one of the things they proved is that it
actually doesn't make a difference if
you're reading good typography or bad
typography you still retain the same
information you still read the same
speed
so like bat typography doesn't slow you
down good typography doesn't make your
job of reading easier
so you're kind of like all right well
that's sort of weird um
but the same study also proved that or
found that good typography induces a
good mood
and that's probably something you've
heard quoted before a lot of a lot of
tight people like to bring it up
but what they found which i think is
really cool is they gave people
something to read
and they had like their one section of
people read something that was set in
bad typography but they gave them like a
present first they're like here you go
here's a present go read this bad
typography and at the end those people
were in just as good of a mood or the
same good mood
as the people who were given no present
but got to read good typography
so the obvious conclusion is good
typography is like giving your users a
present
right but i mean maybe not that
literal but it's actually true having
good typography puts people in a good
mood
makes you look better and you know
having people in a good mood having
people more
you know thinking more highly of you is
a pretty good thing to gain by good
typography
and of course a little bit of taiwan
typography will give you really really
great results
you know if you spend even just a few
minutes at any point in time in your
process or any point of room
in your process you'll get some really
good results and it's not something that
you even need to be
um you know a type typography expert for
just by paying attention to a few of the
things i'll list out
you're going to be so much more awesomer
at typography and that's awesomer is
totally a word
um yeah but responsive web design has
totally changed the way we think about
web typography
um you know suddenly we're doing this
thing where we're setting type
that's what you call it even if it's css
and stuff setting type because we are
serious
type people as web designers now even
though one day we weren't but now we are
yes um not that i'm scarred by that or
anything
uh so we're suddenly putting type in
these containers that can change any
size at any time we're basically like
making our sites and containers do this
all the time and we're going to throw
type in there
and we're doing it on purpose so we used
to set up our style rules for type just
once right we just set them once be like
we're done it's a fixed container it's
good
and if we do that now you know we just
set our styles for text once
the same styles that give us this which
maybe isn't so bad it's some small text
in a small little container maybe it's
like some sort of mobile view or
something
but the same styles that give us that
give us this on larger screens when it
becomes responsive
um and this is not okay this is
completely horrible and no one would
ever want to read
it like it's impossible to read even if
it wasn't so small just having line
lengths that long
no one would ever want to read it and
sadly with responsive design we've been
subjecting to people reading our sites
to things very similar to this way more
than we should
not saying anyone this room has done it
but yeah you've seen it uh you've you've
gone to sites just been like
what is going on um and and so we need
to stop this on the internet because in
fact
when you put line lengths this long on
the internet it makes the cats behind
the internet cry
and we really can't do that so if not
if nothing else cats are on the internet
and long line lengths make them cry all
right
on a roll so now we've established that
everyone wants to keep their line
lengths in check
obviously um responsive web design or
typography for responsive web design
my titles are getting so long you know
what kind of goals
might that have you know if things have
changed we've got these flexible
containers what goals are we going for
now
i would suggest that we kind of have two
goals to be consistent
in some way shape or form like visually
hopefully somewhat consistent to help
project a consistent message or some
crazy idea like that
um and also to be easily readable no
matter what size or what sort of
situation you're being viewed in
sounds like a couple pretty good goals
so let's look at how to meet them
because clearly that's where i'm going
with a list like this
so what can we do to bring more more
consistency to our type
in responsive web design the very first
thing
the main thing we can do is to set a
scale um because consistency makes you
look good
and the first thing everyone says when
they talk about a typographic scale
is that robert bringher said you should
use one right
of course totally heard that and he did
see it's right there
he totally did say that but he wrote
this book originally like a gajillion
years ago
in internet time why should we listen to
this now so i have an even better reason
and that's the consistency factor
the idea of keeping a consistent look to
your type um
really makes you look way more
professional looks things more planned
out and more composed
and that consistency helps carry a
similar feel across the board of any
sort of size
that your type's being viewed at and
it's not like people reading your set
are going to be like
hmm looking at this on my phablet i've
noticed that the ratio between the h2
and the h3 is exactly the same as it was
on my desktop
but they're never going to say that
because that sounds ridiculous
but in their minds people recognize that
and that consistency is totally going to
do you some favors
and then there's also the idea of
consistency being having a consistent
base having something that already looks
good
is going to be 100 million times easier
maybe not 100 million but at least 100
times easier for you to adjust as you go
i tend to exaggerate numbers anyway so
scale equals consistency
and that is really really awesome
so has anyone has anyone here worked
with typographic scales before
a few just a little bit okay
we'll talk about some math for a second
so typographic scale is really just a
ratio
and this one is the golden ratio which i
don't know if you've noticed but a lot
of times
on the internet we find out it exists in
little dotted lines and triangles and
all the logos of all of the worlds
um that may not actually be true i think
that gets added later
it's a bad design joke anyways um
it's basically a ratio where you take a
certain you know you multiply
the different sizes in your type see if
you start at like 12 you multiply to get
the next size up you multiply by 1.68
and you keep going
until you get a list of numbers like
this and maybe this would be in pixels
if i was using that scale
um i rounded them because decimals and
pixels make me feel weird
um you could also do the same thing with
ms and it might look like that decimals
and m's are totally okay
and you would get these numbers from
some place well you could just make them
up yourself by doing a little
multiplication
but i like to get them from
modularscale.com which is a tool that
tim brown put together
that you can just enter in a couple
numbers hit go and it'll do all this
multiplication for you
it'll give you sizes and pixels m's base
16 m's and
percent of 13. uh the first three are
pretty useful i'm not really sure
percent of 13 is
um and these scales can have as much
meaning or as little meaning as you want
you've probably read some articles
sometimes where people are like oh and i
picked the scale because it was like
based off a major fifth and this font
was designed by beethoven
or something um i made that up and it
was horrible
but you know they have these crazy
stories about why they picked this scale
and that those are great stories but
that's not an important part of picking
a scale
if you pick a typographic scale and you
want to use it because you like it and
it looks good and it fits what you're
trying to do
that's enough reason for me you don't
have to have you can make up a story
like that if you want but you don't have
to have
a story like that and one other thing
about scales is that scales um
are not gospel basically you get this
list of numbers and you can use those to
assign your different type sizes you
know
um pick your size for your h2s your h1s
and everything else but
you know if you're if you're looking at
a scale like oh
apparently i have to go through this way
if you're looking at a scale like this
and you decide like oh you know i
decided my h2s were going to be 25
pixels
in size but i really like them to be
just a little bit smaller don't throw
out your scale just set it to like 22
and be fine with it because
um you as a human with eyes and a brain
are smarter than straight up math
anytime when it comes to what looks
right and what looks more balanced
so you can always fudge them a little
for the human factor
all right so that's what we can do for
consistency and scales if you haven't
used them or typographic scales despite
them sounding maybe a little bit weird
are pretty darn awesome to use for that
um so what can we do to typeset well
when our containers are flexing all over
the darn place
yes so um there's three main things we
need to consider when it comes to
balancing
readable type or keeping type readable
and if i was like an infomercial right
now i would have like well i actually
already did have flash bulbs and little
explosions didn't i
um well i'd have more of those and i
probably tell you like i could sell you
for 9.99 the three secrets to like
setting type
and um well three secrets to setting
readable type but i'm not gonna get that
crazy with it
um because that's sort of silly but
there's three things that are kind of
considered the
i guess macro typography or something
like that the three things you
need to have in balance to keep type
readable first is size
second is letting and the third is
measure
those are the super typographic names
for them in css they are font size
line height and width yay so those three
things
looking at just those three things you
can get stuff looking amazingly readable
very easily um when a body of text is
hard to read one of these three things
is out of whack
so they all are kind of related to and
as you kind of adjust them with their
fancy little faders you can pretend
that's what we're really doing if you
adjust any one of them
or change any one of them especially
drastically you need to adjust the other
two to make something that's still more
balanced
and the relationship isn't like a linear
mathematical thing it's not like well if
you increase measure
by two pixels you must increase leading
by half a pixel
it's nothing that literal and that
linear
it's more just by you know when you
adjust one you have to get your balance
back
and the goal isn't really like black and
white rules of like this is better
it's more of just a goal of creating
something that's in good taste
and we all have pretty good taste i mean
we're here right so we can do that
so also according to robert bringhurst
the optimal length or the most optimal
length for a comfortable measure of
reading is 45 to 75 characters
you've probably heard that sometimes too
it comes up kind of a lot
that's considered a comfortable measure
for reading line length on the internet
i've noticed that we've kind of changed
this a little bit sort of interesting
because i know a lot of you guys
probably read sites and then totally go
and count the characters per line
um but if you did because you know if
you haven't already i mean
um we tend to go up to around 100 pretty
easily and those sites are actually
still pretty easy to read
so 45 ish to 100 or 45 to 75 up to 100
main point is that it's a range and
we're really dealing with ranges here
there's no
i mean kind of like what mike was just
saying earlier it's like there's kind of
no absolutes right like pixels are
about this close to becoming meaningless
right now for web design so
everything is ranges and and things that
look good within a certain range
characters per line of what's readable
is also a range
so it kind of fits with that a little
bit
alright so what can we do with this
information and actually maybe get to
some code
because you know there has to be code in
this talk um so one approach i like to
use for keeping line links in check is
something
that i like to call type tweak points um
i'm pretty sure i didn't invent that
name but it sounds cool and basically
it's approach number one for keeping or
my first approach for keeping
text comfortably readable no matter what
your containing size might be
um in tweakpoints is a pretty cool term
that i i first heard from the spark box
guys out of ohio
um and i really like the idea of them
because it's the idea of like it's not
like your design is broken it's just
like there's these points where things
just need a little bit of help
that's yeah that's kind of more what's
going on so these
are actually creating a set of um media
queries or a set of break points or
tweak points whatever you want to call
them
that are type specific i actually make a
whole set just for the type
um and i find them this is crazy by
checking and like actually
reading things and checking them on
various devices and sizes for the
examples i'm going to show you today
i have a super simple like stripped down
just type example so we can look at the
styles that will actually affect that
um it's definitely not the most
practical and we're just going to look
at it by resizing our browser but
obviously
in the real world we'd actually look at
this on you know actual device things
and that sort of thing oh and i should
also point out
um actually i'll point that out later so
tweak points
what what what we do to kind of do this
of this approach
start with using a scale um using
relative units like m's or rims
um i'm actually going to use i mean i'm
going to be using rums because
um i've kind of noticed they have some
decent support these days that's kind of
cool um but m's would be pretty much the
same situation
um when line legs get too long according
to our 45 to 75 characters ish
we had a media query which i have
conveniently shortened to mq
not sure why just for fun and we adjust
the base font size
based on that new width and then
evaluate the font size and line height
from there just to make sure we have
some balance
so that's kind of the trick to it
oh and adjust more if needed of course
there might always be more to adjust
so let's take a look at what that looks
like so here's my super simple example
it's a super simple type centric i keep
fighting there's a screen over there too
it's in both places
this simple example um and we've just
got some text
it's conveniently from goldilocks
because you know we're looking for like
a nice
medium range of things that's good right
okay maybe it's
not so good and so it's the breakfast
drama of goldilocks and the three bears
so i usually start out with something
kind of mobilely sized something
that's going to look good on the
smallest size kind of phone size
here on the screen looks a little tiny
but on the phones it looks kind of not
it looks pretty good
so i was pretty happy with that as a
starting point and for my starting point
i have my base font size as it turns out
set to 75 um and then i assigned all my
you know um in here my h1s i have this
like leading paragraph and then my body
text
that was all set off the scale that i
used um the same numbers from the
previous example
from the previous um scale list sorry so
i have my
my original fonts our base font size set
to 75
and the other thing i would point out is
that the line height was set to 1.4
which is a unitless
measurement and while we can't do things
really in css like set a min line height
and max line height
this is kind of a close second so unit
list is pretty awesome for these it'll
kind of scale with
the font size as i'm sure you know and
then as in my leading paragraph
i set that font size to 1.618 you might
remember from our fancy scale golden
ratio yay that means it'll be amazing
um bottom margin set from the scale as
well and a line height that's just a
little bit smaller because generally
bigger text little less line height is a
good idea and that's going to usually
look a little more balanced
and then i had some stuff set for my h1
as well but
i want to get through all these too um
then usually what i would do is throw in
some
lorem ipsum some nice lorem ipsum with a
couple little asterisks in there one at
45 characters and one at 75 characters
in
because i really hate counting so this
is a really good visual way to do it
and it's actually an idea i stole from
trent walton who he probably also does
not like counting
so i think that's why i think he's cool
um
that might be the only yeah because
that's one reason to agree with people i
also don't like counting
yeah um so we have those in there and
then we basically just start
seeing what happens when our containing
when
our page gets bigger and our main texts
container
gets bigger and bigger so eventually we
hit a point where we have those two
asterisks on one line we're like yeah
this is probably getting a bit too long
to read
yep i mean you'll see notice on the body
copy we have that both on one line it's
getting a bit too long to read
our lead-in paragraph that's super huge
and dynamic or dramatic rather
it's still doing okay but our body copy
needs some help so this point
i put in um one of the type tweak points
which is basically setting a media query
at approximately 615 pixels um and
bumping up the font size to 100
then i should probably point out as i
mentioned before but then i stopped
myself
is um you know this code is definitely
not the kind of code you'd be like copy
and paste and use it in your um
in your own projects write media queries
however you would like you know
use sas all that cool stuff but this is
just an easy way to demonstrate it here
on our super simple example so um
as we keep going we would make some
other changes maybe decide to add
another one in around
850 for this one i bumped up the font
size and then that font size started
looking a little bit big
so i made the line height a little bit
smaller as well and
these sorts of things are there you can
get a whole list of rules of like when
line height should be smaller or bigger
um usually like larger text you want a
smaller line height
text that has lots of space within the
letters you want more line height but
really the easiest way to do it
is to find where things look a little
broken find where your line lengths look
a little bit too long and then start
adjusting things and see what looks
better to you
because we're all really good judges of
what's easy to read it's just a matter
of taking the time to look at
it and adjust things and if your first
adjustment makes it look worse
try going the other way i think that's
the easiest way to learn this stuff and
to really get a feel for it
so we kept going and then in the very
end i ended up
setting one for 1200 pixels and
basically
um you know we would end up with
something that might look a little like
this oops nope we wouldn't
that's the next point so biggest
question is you know for something
simple like this is where do you stop
and in real life situations when you're
not just mocking up a page about
goldilocks
you're going to run into something other
than your text needing to stop getting
bigger
maybe you know you you don't want to be
in a situation where your text is this
big
and you have like this little video or
this little image like something else in
your design will generally stop you
and have you have to put in a max width
somewhere um
and when that happens then you're good
to go but for this particular one it was
just kind of an arbitrary one where i
set my max width of my container
at about um like 900 pixels or something
like that
and these these tweak points that you
put in for the type don't just have to
be adjusting
your font size and your line height i
think those are the first two things you
should look at to balance out your
reading
but you can do more interesting things
as well for example the new alistar part
redesign
they actually switch out to georgia pro
condensed
on their smaller viewport more
mobily-ish views
and if you notice looking at these a
little carefully because they're very
close
the characters in the left-hand one on
the mobile view one or the smallest one
take up less space than the ones that
when they get bigger so what they've
done
is switch to a font that's a little more
condensed they can get more characters
in
on these tiny or thin viewports um
but still be able to keep the text
bigger because a lot of the time
depending on the font you pick
you'll notice when you get down to these
smaller viewport sizes to get a readable
length
you start having a really small font
size and then it's like well is that
really more comfortable
if it's a good um you know comfortable
measure but it's so tiny i'm like
squinting at my phone
that's not comfortable anymore so your
font choices affect this as well
i think that's a pretty good trick and
you could even maybe do it bigger on the
other side
you know a lot of web type comes as
display faces so you could do something
when it gets really big to
put in one of the display weights so
then our end thing will look something
like this i'm just going to go through
it kind of quick because we have two
more
um so it starts out small expands and
gets bigger we
hit our various uh type tweak points and
then eventually it stops our container
stops getting bigger and we allow our
margins to get bigger instead
so let's type a graphic tweak points
which is a terrible name i've given this
approach that
um definitely is not something i
invented but something that
you get gets used quite a bit so we
start with our scale using relative
units that's the biggest most important
thing and then we can adjust our base
font size to get our scale
basically to scale and we set a cutoff
point based on some other factor usually
then our type
and my nmedia queries ended up looking
like this
so you might have noticed that i
switched from pixels to m based media
queries
usually since it's pretty easy to get
something to tell you how many pixels
wide your browser is not so easy to get
something to tell how many
m's wide it is i start with pixels and
then convert them over
um i like the m based media queries a
lot better because it kind of makes you
more
resolution independent right like if
somebody um is viewing
is it kind of doesn't matter how many
pixels are any more m's which are
essentially roughly based on the 16
pixel increments
you know if they get bigger because
someone zooms in or something you have
fewer m's
and then you might hit one of your other
media queries as well so it really takes
you away from pixels and takes you away
from that
um you know makes you more resolution
independent pretty cool way to do it
um and cloud four has a probably even
though it's a little more than a year
old probably the best reason
of why you should move towards those on
their blog as well
so um to get these particular numbers i
just ended up dividing by 16.
um but when it comes to the mba stuff
you kind of end up playing things by ear
a little bit more you know relying less
on actual numbers and actual pixel
pixels and just finding those good
ranges
so one problem with this approach though
is that um m's don't equal m's anymore
you know if i have um increased my base
font size my m's
vertically yes i screw that up sometimes
it's very embarrassing my m's vertically
have actually gotten bigger they're not
approximately 16 pixels anymore right
but my m-based media queries going
horizontally
are still based off the 16 pixel ratio
they don't get bigger
when i increase my base font size um
some people have a really big problem
with this i'm actually kind of okay with
it
i don't know if that makes me weird but
i tend to work in really small teams
where it's like me and a developer or
like me and three other people
and there's probably only like two of us
ever touching the css so we can keep
this straight
um bigger teams maybe that's more of a
problem
um and really lately i've been finding
myself playing by ear more when it comes
to setting these typographic tweak
points of like where i actually change
things
and relying less on exactly how wide my
browser window is and just more on how
things look
and maybe i should make a change here or
there so one other approach besides that
that we can do
emmify things
that's okay that was supposed to be a
funny title it's all right that title
wasn't funny enough for you i totally
have some terrible puns in the subtitle
so if changing good okay yeah you guys
are still awake
you're like oh type makes me sleepy um
if changing your base font size is a
problem which it often can be you know
if that
making your m's not match is a problem
or other reasons is a problem for you
there's other ways to do this as well
and um obviously by keeping things
constant by keeping your base font size
constant your m's will always be
approximately based off 16 ish pixels
i like how all the math we're doing now
for responsive design is like
approximately kind of sorta it's like we
have numbers and they kind of mean stuff
but they kind of don't
it's pretty cool it's great when you
like to make up numbers
so to kind of take this approach
you want to measure your column widths
and m's and this is maybe the main thing
stopping make it or break it point for
people not everyone likes to measure
their widths and ends people have grids
that work
in percentages and all that kind of
thing and they don't want to get away
from that it's okay
you don't have to do it this way but if
you do this is a good way to do it
um you keep your base paste font size
constant
and then you can you keep your
containers fluid when they're smaller
and then when you get to a point a
certain point which we'll talk about in
one second
you stop letting anything get bigger and
you just let your margins get bigger and
you base that on
an m value um because generally kind of
sort of with our fuzzy math some more
um if there's any like super math people
in the house they're probably starting
to feel like a little icky
um but one m is approximately like one m
at least typographically is based off of
a capital m which is
approximately two-ish characters for
most fonts
so if we say 75 characters is our
maximum comfortable reading measure
and we divide that approximately by two
somewhere in around 32 m should be the
max size
of our of our main text container and if
it never goes over 32 ms
we'll never have more than 75 characters
and we will always be at a comfortable
readable length
yay math
um so we would end up with something
like this when it's very small
we keep it nice and flexible oops sorry
that
when we get to more more medium length
um we're still a little flexible but at
some point in that sort of medium range
we hit our maximum 32
ms and then when we do that things get a
little bit bigger but only our margins
get bigger
and as we get bigger and bigger our
margin gets huger and huger um if this
were
a real project and not goldilocks and
the three bears we might you know kick
up to two columns or something like that
but in this case it just hangs out there
in the center all by its lonely self
and our font sizes never actually change
so that's another approach keeping your
line length
in a comfortable way but without having
to make well i guess making fewer tweaks
so widths and everything in ms keeps you
nice and resolution independent that is
pretty awesome
um there's still an option to make
adjustments here or there you know you
can make more adjustments if you want to
make those little tweak points in
addition to doing this one
and it doesn't work well with all grid
making approaches um i know some people
who are like the idea
of making setting up their grids and m's
and they just kind of like freak out and
don't want to talk to me anymore so it's
okay
i mean i'll get over it i'll just do the
other version instead
i end up having to work with a lot of
different teams so you know i'm used to
adapting so one more approach since we
said we do three
and i realize i have no idea how i'm
doing on time because my counter didn't
start so i'm sorry about that
um one other approach that i've been
playing with a little bit and haven't
really gotten to use for real yet
is vh and vw vh is my favorite
obviously get it val head v8 okay
i'm like that's awesome i have a unit
named after me oh
um these are gonna these don't really
have enough support to use anywhere
real just yet but they're really
interesting um
100 vw equals all of the viewport width
essentially
um so one is like one percent and you
can set up something that will
constantly change the font size and even
like your margins and line height and
everything you want
in all directions based on your viewport
and it just changes all the time
well except most browsers make you
refresh before it updates but once they
fix that
all the time squishy it's great but it's
kind of drastic
for example these two are both set to um
2vw for font size this one you're never
going to be able to read even if that
was on a real phone
not going to happen it's way too tiny so
it kind of scales to any proportion at
all and when it gets really big
you know kind of looks okay but it
doesn't handle small size as well
but i do like what it's doing to my
heading i mean that's kind of cool
a little small in the small end too but
it's maybe a little bit more of a
headings thing
so these guys are definitely fun because
squishing things in all directions and
making your margins change and your font
size change is really fun to do
um but it still needs limits somewhere
probably especially on the low end
because that text was so tiny
i don't even know if like a magnifying
glass would help you out with that it
was pretty bad
um and it's pretty kick-ass for titles
and display copy i think that's the kind
of place
these are really going to come in handy
places where you might have used
something like fit text and use
javascript to make sure
it always made your text size big enough
to fill your whole window you might be
able to use these instead
kind of nice okay
so responsive design strangely enough is
more than just making your boxes all
flexi
so typography for responsive design is
also more than just fitting them into
flexi containers
so i wanted to talk a little bit about
what we can do to make
what we can do with our type to make it
i guess basically more aware that we're
under different conditions not just in
flexi boxes
um but i realize i've been doing this
like all day like yay this is my new
dance
anyways um so things we can do with type
that consider devices at least just a
little
um because we don't have any real
reliable way still to really find out
like what someone's connection speed or
anything is but
we can kind of make some assumptions and
i'll go with the assumptions for now
until we have something better
so loading web fonts can take a while it
can take a really long while
um you especially notice it on mobile
situations where
generally speaking your connection might
be a bit slower for lack of a better way
to measure
and you know you're gonna you're gonna
see that you'll actually notice this
loading thing happens so
there's a couple things we can do to
make this happen more gracefully um we
can use font stacks still
i know things like services like type
kit and font deck and everything they
give you the css samples and it's
usually
like your awesome web type and then like
serif
there should always be something between
your awesome web type and serif always
um you know just don't just copy and
paste that because sometimes
this is a little sad and terrible
sometimes your web fonts won't load at
all
don't want to scare anyone but it's true
i mean not just in mobile situations
there's actually
like um you know ad blockers and stuff
that will block things like type kit and
then suddenly you're on your fallback
fault so they better be awesome
this is a chart that is scary but true
and it goes to try to show you
um what font exists on all mobile
platforms none
good luck with that so basically at some
point no matter what on some devices
you're going to be stuck with your basic
serif or san serif
it's also possible to hide web fonts
from
mobile situations if you want to if
you're okay with basing
thin viewport means probably mobile
maybe not really good connection speed
and we can do things like actually by
not calling our awesome web font
it won't get loaded but that's only if
you actually load in um
your web font through pure css a little
trickier if you're using
javascript but you know javascript can
handle that whole like
if this then that stuff too i've heard
of people taking some approaches of
creating like a light type kit and heavy
type
type type kit one with fewer fonts one
with more serving the lighter one to
mobile
and this is a great article since i
don't have any time to get into it but
css tricks
did some great things and examples about
preventing the performance hit of custom
fonts
there are also web phone events that we
can that we can look into
and they are seriously awesome google
has put these together and you can
actually use the google web font loader
to get
um events of the situation your web web
fonts loading
um with any service or situation for
loading web fonts that you want
it comes built into type kit but you can
set up this google one even if you're
rolling your own at font face setup
um the way it works you get some classes
one for when your web fonts are loading
called wf loading the naming structure
is amazing
obviously when they're inactive means
they haven't loaded at all and when
they're active and you can set some
different styles based on that
and this comes in handy especially for
titles or really important texts like
taglines or something like that
where you want to really handle every
detail of how it's going to get swapped
out
but from its default font or the
fallback font but then what it gets
swapped out with once your web fonts
load so you can control every step of
the way on this
and make sure that like when it's just
set to plain old serif it still fits in
the same box it's going to fit in when
you're
using your good proxima nova or whatever
else so
those are pretty handy i've been going
through a whole lot of stuff
so the very last part that i want to
talk about um because i'm assuming i
only have a couple minutes left
is um responsive typography for the
future i mean
there's a lot more we can do with with
type and fonts
than just fitting them into flexi boxes
and trying to figure out if we have a
good connection speed or not to load our
stuff and
handling that loading function one thing
that's really interesting and i didn't
talk about it too much
is just the idea that um on retina
displays your fonts look different we've
all seen it we've got
you know high resolution phones or high
density phones whatever you want to call
them retina display phones
and then regular old monitors and
on retina displays your type is going to
appear lighter even though it's not
lighter basically because it's higher
resolution
so the folks over who make ia writer
have actually
done some things or done some
experimenting with graded fonts and
basically these fonts are aware
of you know what your resolution that
they're dealing with is and they
actually would serve up a slightly
bolder version
to retina displays so that it ends up
looking exactly the same
as the coarser lower resolution version
so it's like a font that knows what
resolution it's being displayed at and
adjusts itself accordingly
that would be pretty cool to play with i
think
um so that's one way that things could
be getting pretty interesting
another way things will be getting
pretty interesting is there's i believe
this is a series actually
that um that nick has been writing on a
list apart um but he's suggesting that
um
you know all fonts have some hinting
included with them and that's basically
instructions of how to make their
awesome smooth curves
um translate to course harsh pixels
and how that's going to happen and
hinting tells them how to do that
but he's suggesting that maybe hinting
could do more than that
like what if the hinting instructions of
your font could tell it hey
skinny viewport maybe condense your
characters a little bit give me like a
condensed version
or like hey a really really big viewport
why don't we go with the more wide
version
so that kind of things those kinds of
things could be
actually embedded within our fonts and
our fonts could be smart enough
you know we wouldn't have to swap them
out ourselves they could actually know
um
and i think that's kind of cool the idea
of like pulling up a web font and
loading it up and having it know like
the resolution and adjusting for that
knowing what kind of viewport size i'm
dealing with
smart fonts sound pretty awesome so
the whole idea of responsive and
typography i think is heading to some
pretty interesting directions
i'm kind of excited about all this stuff
and hopefully maybe you guys
are a little bit too so that wraps up
our journey of typography for responsive
design
a lot to cover in like 30 minutes so
thanks for for following along
and yeah thanks for having me and
talking about responsive typography for
a little while
um i know that we're having a party on
the beach later and there's probably
nothing more fun than talking about
typography on the beach
right so if you guys want to chat later
about any type stuff let me know if you
want to chat on the internet that's
where to find me
and thanks very much